[Music]  well it's a wrap on behalf of the next  live show crew thank you for hanging out  with us the last three days we had a  great time showing the Google cloud next  19 experience with you but it doesn't  end here everything with live streams  the keynotes the recaps the next live  show experience and all the sessions  that next will be available to watch  share and re-watch on our video  on-demand page at G dokgo slash next  on-air next 19 is about to go global as  it heads to Tokyo and then London later  this year follow us at GTO slash cloud  next to stay in the know so long from  San Francisco thank you so much for  watching and we'll see you next year  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]